Diversity training in the workplace is generally aimed at fostering cohesion, mutual respect, and understanding among people of various backgrounds. The thinking is that diversity training can stop some problematic behaviors, which can sometimes lead to a hostile workplace and issue not just for employees, but employers as well. Diversity training is also thought to improve morale, help workers feel more committed to their jobs, help companies recruit and retain a diverse workforce, and even increase productivity and creativity. But does it do these things? Does requiring employees, contractors, and vendors to adhere to a set of diversity and inclusion principles change people's inherent biases,
工作场所的多样性培训通常旨在促进各种背景的人之间的凝聚力、相互尊重和理解。其理念是，多样性培训可以制止一些有问题的行为，这些行为有时会导致充满敌意的工作环境，这不仅是员工的问题，也是雇主的问题。人们还认为，多样性培训可以提升士气，帮助员工对工作更有奉献精神，帮助公司招聘和留住多元化的员工队伍，甚至还能提高生产力和创造力。但它真的能起到这些作用吗？要求员工、承包商和供应商遵守一套多元化和包容性原则，是否能改变人们固有的偏见（
assuming they have them, and stop unwanted behaviors? Or can it trigger resentment or other negative outcomes? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Calvin Lye, an assistant professor of psychology at Washington University in St. Louis. His research is focused on implicit biases, those automatic or unconscious thoughts that many of us hold. In particular, he studies how these biases can change and whether interventions can reduce their impact on our behavior. He has studied the research into diversity training and has some interesting insights into its effectiveness. Welcome to speak to.
假设他们有的话），并制止不良行为？还是说这会引发怨恨或其他负面结果？欢迎收听“心理学热线”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是圣路易斯华盛顿大学心理学助理教授卡尔文·赖（Calvin Lai）博士。他的研究重点是内隐偏见，即我们许多人持有的那些自动的或无意识的想法。特别是，他研究这些偏见如何发生改变，以及干预措施能否减少它们对我们行为的影响。他研究了关于多样性培训的研究，并对其有效性有一些有趣的见解。欢迎做客。
Speaking of psychology, Dr. Lai. Hi. Pleasure to be here. Well, let's start by talking about what your lab and other psychology labs are studying in the way of interventions to change people's implicit biases. What are those interventions look like and how do they connect to the kind of diversity training that we're seeing in workplaces today? That's a great question. So in my discipline of social psychology, there's been a lot of interest in what we can do about implicit biases. and one of the kind of most obvious things that we realize is like, okay, well, if these implicit biases exist,
“心理学热线”，赖博士。嗨。很高兴来到这里。好吧，让我们从你的实验室和其他心理学实验室在改变人们内隐偏见的干预措施方面正在研究的内容开始谈起。这些干预措施是什么样的？它们与我们在当今工作场所看到的多元化培训有什么联系？这是一个很好的问题。因此，在我的社会心理学学科中，人们对我们能对内隐偏见做些什么产生了很大的兴趣。我们意识到的最明显的事情之一就是，好吧，既然这些内隐偏见存在，
then perhaps we can simply reduce them, make them go away. And the program of research in trying to make implicit biases go away has indicated that it's actually quite difficult to do so. Implicit biases are formed over a lifetime of experience. And so interventions that try to kind of undo them over the course of a couple minutes or a couple hours often have a really powerful short-term effect in reducing the implicit biases, but then they'll bounce back within several days. And so that's where a new set of approaches have come about in terms of thinking about if we can't change the implicit biases themselves, how can we work around them? How can we arm people with the right set of motivations or educate them with the right set of knowledge so that instead of making them go away entirely, we are better equipped to work around the fact that they can impact our behavior. And so where there's been a lot of interest but not yet that much published research is understanding the power of diversity training in doing away with some of these subtle biases that we might see in the workplace.
那么也许我们可以简单地减少它们，让它们消失。旨在让内隐偏见消失的研究项目表明，要做到这一点实际上相当困难。内隐偏见是一生的经验形成的。因此，试图在几分钟或几小时内消除它们的干预措施，通常在减少内隐偏见方面具有非常强大的短期效果，但随后它们会在几天内反弹。因此，这就产生了一套新的方法：如果我们不能改变内隐偏见本身，我们该如何绕过它们？我们如何用正确的动机武装人们，或者用正确的知识教育人们，这样一来，我们不是让它们彻底消失，而是更好地装备自己，以应对它们会影响我们行为这一事实？因此，人们对此产生了很大的兴趣，但尚未发表太多关于理解多样性培训在消除我们在工作场所中可能看到的其中一些微妙偏见方面的效力的研究。
or otherwise. In a recent research interview, you looked at hundreds of studies of these implicit bias interventions, and you didn't find much evidence that they could produce long-lasting changes in people's biases or their behavior, which you just said. Could you talk more about that review and what does that mean for diversity training? Right. I want to emphasize that what we found in that meta-analysis is quite distinct from what we might think of as diversity training, and it's easy to confuse the two. So when we are thinking of diversity training, we're often thinking of these kind of professional development or continuing education sessions that might last anywhere between 30 minutes, an hour to several days that can take the form of either some
或其他地方。在最近的一次研究访谈中，你查阅了数百项关于这些内隐偏见干预措施的研究，你并没有发现多少证据表明它们能够对人们的偏见或行为产生持久的改变，正如你刚才所说的那样。你能多谈谈那篇综述，以及这对多样性培训意味着什么吗？好的。我想强调的是，我们在该元分析中发现的结果与我们可能认为的多元化培训有很大不同，这两者很容易混淆。因此，当我们想到多元化培训时，我们通常会想到这些职业发展或继续教育课程，它们的时间可能从30分钟、一小时到几天不等，其形式既可以是
module you complete on your human resources learning system to this kind of, you know, really intensive in-person experience. When social psychologists, And other researchers have studied how to change implicit bias, which is what we looked at in that meta-analysis. That was more on interventions that were more therapeutic in nature. Can we give people the right set of experiences or therapeutic experiences that will permanently reduce these implicit biases? And oftentimes we're finding that you can't make the implicit biases go away. And to the extent that you can change this implicit biases, those changes might not amount to downstream changes in behavior, which I think is reason to think
你在人力资源学习系统上完成的某个模块，也可以是这种非常密集的线下体验。当社会心理学家和其他研究人员研究如何改变内隐偏见时，这正是我们在那项元分析中研究的内容。那更多的是关于本质上更具治疗性的干预措施。我们能否给人们提供合适的经历或治疗经历，从而永久减少这些内隐偏见？而我们经常发现的是，你无法让内隐偏见消失。从你能改变这些内隐偏见的程度来看，这些改变可能不会转化为后续的行为改变，我认为这是有理由认为
that instead of trying to target implicit biases directly, we ought to be thinking about some of these other strategies. And what are these other strategies? Right. The other strategies include arming people with the right set of motivations or habits so that if they are in situations where they're vulnerable to bias, they can catch themselves and override their biases, right? So rather than making the biases go away, just arming people with better strategies for regulating them, or policy or procedural changes in organizations so that people are less inclined to act on their bias in the first place.
与其试图直接针对内隐偏见，我们更应该考虑其他一些策略。这些其他策略是什么？对。其他策略包括用正确的动机或习惯来武装人们，这样如果他们处于容易产生偏见的境地，他们就能察觉到自己并凌驾于偏见之上，对吧？因此，与其让偏见消失，不如用更好的策略来武装人们以调节偏见，或者在组织中进行政策或程序上的更改，这样人们从一开始就不太倾向于根据偏见行事。
Changing, for example, how hiring and promotions happen so that people are less likely to take race or gender into account based on how the decision-making structure is set up. Let's talk for a moment about police forces where biases may have played a role in some of the recent high-profile shootings of unarmed black people. So most police forces, as I understand it, have diversity training today. And yet, given the prevalence of these types of shootings, is that an indication that something just isn't working? Is there something else happening in police departments where people who might have issues with bias who maybe didn't get screened out at some point? or they have aggression problems and they're walking around with weapons on their hips. Is that some kind of a combination that we can't account for in training? Yeah, that's a great question.
例如，改变招聘和晋升的方式，以便根据决策结构的建立方式，人们不太可能将种族或性别因素考虑在内。我们来谈谈警察部队，在最近针对无武装黑人的高调枪击事件中，偏见可能在其中发挥了一定的作用。据我了解，如今大多数警察部队都有多样性培训。然而，鉴于这类枪击事件的普遍性，这是否表明某些环节根本没有起作用？警察部门内部是否还发生了其他事情，比如那些可能存在偏见问题、可能在某个阶段没有被筛查出来的人？或者他们有攻击性问题，腰里别着武器到处走。这是我们在培训中无法解释的某种组合吗？是的，这是一个很好的问题。
I think the problems of police use of force, disproportionate use of force, racial inequities in use of force, are a kind of complex, multifaceted problem, right, that range from issues with, problem individuals all the way up to systemic issues related to policies related to accountability and what types of use of force are allowable within a given department. And so the way that I think about it is that given that the cause of these issues in terms of these racial disparities in treatment are so many, it's unlikely that any single policy reform is going to make the problem go away overnight. But what we can do as researchers and active-minded citizens is to pay attention to, well, which of these things have a great track record
我认为警察使用武力的问题、不成比例地使用武力、使用武力方面的种族不平等，是一个复杂的多面性问题，对吧？它涵盖了从个人问题到与问责制政策相关的系统性问题，以及特定部门内允许使用何种武力的问题。因此，我的看法是，鉴于这些待遇上的种族差异的原因如此之多，任何单一的政策改革都不太可能让这个问题在一夜之间消失。但作为研究人员和有积极思维的公民，我们能做的是关注，这些事情中哪一些在
of curbing or preventing unjustified uses of force or other issues like that. When it comes to diversity training in police departments, the research right now is that there's not that much standardization, and there's just not that many studies that have been published on the topic yet. And so it's more of a big question mark than anything about the extent to which they are efficacious at preventing racial disparities. Diversity training is being implemented in a lot of different workplaces. You see it in schools and corporations, the government. And some of our listeners may remember when Starbucks closed down at stores for a day to train all its baristas after there was an unfortunate encounter between a manager and some black customers in Philadelphia.
遏制或防止不当使用武力或其他类似问题方面有着良好的记录。说到警察部门的多样性培训，目前的研究表明，还没有那么多的标准化，而且关于这个主题已经发表的研究还不是很多。因此，关于它们在防止种族差异方面有多大成效，与其说有定论，不如说是一个巨大的问号。多样性培训正在许多不同的工作场所实施。你在学校、公司和政府部门都能看到它。我们的一些听众可能还记得，在费城一名经理和几名黑人顾客发生不幸遭遇后，星巴克曾关闭门店一天，对其所有咖啡师进行培训。
Does effective diversity training look different in different places or are there common threads? Yes. So I think when we think about what diversity training is, at the end of the day, it's just teaching. It's just education. So the way that you might teach effectively to one audience or the things that you need to teach to a particular audience are going to be totally different depending on the context, right? the types of issues related to bias that a bunch of cashiers or waiters or waitresses or service industry folks will need might look very different from folks who are in management or executive positions, right? They're dealing with very different types of issues related to diversity inclusion and diversity trainings ought to be kind of targeted to where the problems are, right?
有效 Diversity training 在不同的地方看起来是否不同，或者是否存在共同点？是的。所以我想，当我们思考什么是多样性培训时，归根结底，它只是教学。它只是教育。因此，你向一个受众有效教学的方式，或者你需要向特定受众教授的内容，将根据上下文完全不同，对吧？一大群收银员、服务员或服务行业人员需要的与偏见相关的问题类型，可能看起来与处于管理层或行政职位的人截然不同，对吧？他们正在处理与多元化包容性相关的截然不同的问题，多元化培训应该针对问题所在，对吧？
There isn't necessarily going to be a one-size-fits-all package that solves all the problems within the span of an hour, a couple hours. And that's led to part of the difficulty in the understanding, you know, do these things work? Because diversity training is this big umbrella for all these different efforts to educate about diversity and inclusion. Well, that's a great point about the difference between, say, a line worker and somebody in the C-suite. Does it, I'm just thinking out a lot a little bit here, but people in the C-suite might be more skilled in perhaps masking the biases. Is that the case, do you think? Has anybody looked at that? I would probably predict that to the extent that there are differences, depending on where you are within a corporate hierarchy, those differences would probably be pretty small.
并不一定存在一个能够在一个小时或几个小时内解决所有问题的“一刀切”的方案。这就导致了理解这些事情是否有效的一部分困难，因为多样性培训是所有这些关于多元化和包容性教育的各种努力的大伞。嗯，关于一线员工和高管层（C-suite）之间的区别，这是一个很好的观点。我想象了一下，C-suite 中的人可能更擅长掩盖偏见。你认为是这样吗？有人研究过这个吗？我可能会预测，就差异而言，根据你在企业等级制度中的位置，这些差异可能相当小。
most of the research on the solid-headed biases suggests that they are largely a problem for everyone. And while some people may express them to greater or less degree, it's not the case that there are certain folks that are immune. In a recent blog post, you highlighted that implicit bias is, you called it pervasive but not inevitable. And you found that about 65% of non-black visitors to a website that measures implicit bias show evidence of, implicit bias against black people, but about 35% don't. And that's kind of a higher percentage of people than I might have thought. Has there been research looking at the differences between people who show evidence of implicit bias and those who don't? Can we learn anything from that? Here's what we do now. First off, I think that in comparison to say our conscious self-reported
关于这种顽固偏见的大多数研究表明，它们在很大程度上是每个人的问题。虽然有些人可能会表现出更多或更程度的偏见，但并不存在某些人免疫的情况。在最近的一篇博客文章中，你强调了内隐偏见，你称之为普遍存在但并非不可避免。你发现，在一个衡量内隐偏见的网站上，大约65%的非黑人访问者表现出对黑人的内隐偏见的证据，而大约35%的人则没有。这比我想象的要高一些。有没有研究探讨过表现出内隐偏见证据的人与没有表现出内隐偏见证据的人之间的差异？我们能从中学到什么吗？这就是我们现在的所作所知。首先，我认为，与我们的意识自我报告的
prejudices, the ones that we can consciously espouse, implicit bias, implicit bias, are much more stable from situation to situation and from day to day. So if you put me in a room with one of my interventions with a person off the street, I could reduce their implicit biases by 50% in five minutes. Now, that will probably bounce back within the next 24 hours, but they are, in some ways, our implicit biases are almost like these chameleons that are adapting to whatever social situation we're moving, we're seeing. And so there are some kind of chronic differences in the levels of implicit bias that people have. But that seems to be a smaller part of the picture of the
偏见（即我们可以有意识地拥护的偏见）相比，内隐偏见从情境到情境、从日到日要稳定得多。因此，如果你把我放在一个房间里，让我带着街头的一个人做我的一项干预措施，我可以在五分钟内将他们的内隐偏变减少50%。现在，这可能会在接下来的24小时内反弹，但在某些方面，我们的内隐偏见几乎就像这些变色龙一样，在适应我们正在进入、正在看到的任何社会情境。因此，人们所拥有的内隐偏见水平存在一些长期差异。但这似乎只是反映了
fact that these implicit biases are in many ways a reflection of the social environment that we live in. But we do know people who have chronically lower implicit biases do tend to act in a more egalitarian manner, tend to be more supportive of egalitarian political policies. and so on. There's one concern that's raised by some people that diversity training and diversity issues can backfire by making people feel resentful and attacked. Is that a valid concern? It is a valid concern. And some of the latest theoretical models often think about, you know, what are the best situations that we want out of or the best conditions for a diversity training? And you don't want people to get so defensive that they shut down and they become more resistant to diversity and inclusion initiatives than before.
这些内隐偏见在很大程度上是我们所生活的社会环境的写照这一事实的一小部分。但是我们确实知道，那些内隐偏见长期较低的人确实倾向于以更平等的态度行事，倾向于更支持平等的政治政策，等等。有些人提出了这样一个担忧：多样性培训和多样性问题可能会引起人们的怨恨和攻击感，从而产生反效果。这是一个合理的担忧吗？这是一个合理的担忧。一些最新的理论模型经常在思考，关于多样性培训，我们想要的最佳情境或最佳条件是什么？你绝对不希望人们产生如此强烈的防御心理，以至于他们关闭心扉，变得比以前更加抵制多元化和包容性倡议。
But at the same time, you don't want them to feel like they're off the hook, right? Sometimes a little bit of feelings of guilt can be quite motivating, right? It means that I've got a problem to solve. And so part of the tight line for people who are in the business of diversity education is how do we motivate people to do something? something about the problem of bias, but at the same time, not put them so far in the defensive way they just shut down and act reactively. So one of the common recommendations from this, the literature on diversity training is that it's often better to make it optional opt-in rather than something that's mandatory. Because when it's mandatory, then some of the sticks in the mud will show up to the training and just be stewing in their resentment during the educational session. But then those might be the people who need it the most and they're not getting it, right?
但与此同时，你又不想让他们觉得自己可以置身事外，对吧？有时，一点点的内疚感可以成为很好的动力，对吧？这意味着我有一个问题需要解决。因此，对于从事多元化教育的人来说，需要走的一条微妙的线是：我们如何激励人们对偏见问题采取行动，但与此同时，又不要让他们产生太强的防御心理以至于关闭心扉并做出反应性的举动。因此，来自多样性培训文献的常见建议之一是，最好将其设为可选的自愿参加，而不是强制性的。因为如果是强制性的，那么一些顽固分子就会出现在培训中，并在整个教育课程中沉浸在怨恨之中。但这些人可能正是最需要它的人，而他们却没有得到它，对吧？
Yeah. And so that's the tricky part, right? Is there a type of best practices for getting diversity education that works for everyone, particular people who need it most? And so where I think right now is that we don't have a lot of standardization. So some educational efforts from, say, one company or one organization might be walking that line really well and other ones might not be. And so what I'm hopeful for, in terms of the next couple years of research is a set of standard best practices for how do we get people in the mental state where they are most receptive to learning about bias and then actually doing something about it within the context of these sessions? So one of the reasons that I wanted to talk to you was there were recent orders from the Trump administration about revamping the diversity training within the federal government because some people in the administration claim that it's, I mean, they've called it racist. they say it's un-American. Have you looked at these trainings that are being used in the federal government and are there real problems there? So, again, there's not that much standardization. So it's kind of all over the board in terms of what people are inclined to do in these trainings. Some of these, again, might be counterproductive.
是的。所以这正是棘手的部分，对吧？是否存在一种适用于所有人的多元化教育的最佳实践类型，特别是对于最需要它的人？因此，我认为目前的现状是，我们没有太多的标准化。因此，来自某家公司或某个组织的某些教育工作在走那条线时可能做得很好，而其他一些则可能没有。因此，我所希望的是，在接下来的几年研究中，能够拥有一套标准的最佳实践，即我们如何让人们进入这样一种精神状态：他们最容易接受有关偏见的教育，然后在这些课程的背景下真正采取行动？我想要和你谈谈的原因之一是，特朗普政府最近发布了关于重组联邦政府内部多样性培训的行政命令，因为政府中的一些人声称，我的意思是，他们称之为种族主义。他们说这是反美国的。你有没有看过联邦政府正在使用的这些培训，那里是否存在真正的问题？所以，再次说明，没有太多的标准化。因此，在人们倾向于在这些培训中做什么方面，可以说是五花八门。其中一些培训可能再次起到适得其反的作用。
But what I do know is at least from speaking to some of my colleagues is that some of the things that are just simple run-of-the-mill educational sessions about things that you would probably see in your psychology 101 or introduction to social psychology class, those things are also being caught underneath this executive order banning education about racism and sexism. And so I worry with this executive order that certainly it may be catching some of these trainings that are counter-effective, but the language is so broad that it's likely capturing a lot of educational efforts that are, at the very least, raising awareness about problems related to racism and sexism in everyday life. You've been talking about how part of the problem is that there isn't standardization. Is it even possible to standardize something like diversity training? I think at the very least we can have a set of best practices, but I think this is a common problem. You know, anytime you look past K-12 education, right, there's just not that much.
但我所知道的是，至少从与我的一些同事交谈中了解到，有些事情只是简单的普通教育课程，关于你可能会在心理学101或社会心理学导论课上看到的内容，这些事情也被卷入了这项禁止有关种族主义和性别歧视教育的行政命令中。因此，我担心这项行政命令肯定会打击到其中一些适得其反的培训，但其语言过于宽泛，以至于很可能涵盖了许多至少在日常生活中提高对种族主义和性别歧视相关问题意识的教育工作。你刚才一直在谈论部分问题在于缺乏标准化。像多样性培训这样的东西，甚至有可能标准化吗？我认为至少我们可以拥有一套最佳实践，但我认为这是一个普遍的问题。你知道，任何时候只要你超越K-12教育，对吧，在继续教育或职业发展课程中通常就是没有那么多的
standardization oftentimes in continuing education or professional development sessions in general. And I think diversity education is just one more place where this is a problem. My hope, though, is that at least that we can establish some standard vocabulary in terms of what are the key educational metrics that we want folks to get out of diversity education. How can we measure them? and what are the best practices that are best aligned for those metrics, right? So you kind of create this level of professionalization that we see in other educational domains, but it just hasn't happened yet, I think, due to the, in some ways, the kind of history and origins of where diversity education came from.
标准化。我认为多样性教育只是又一个存在这个问题的领域。不过，我的希望是，至少我们可以建立一些标准的词汇，来定义我们希望人们从多样性教育中获得的关键教育指标是什么。我们如何衡量它们？哪些是与这些指标最相符的最佳实践，对吧？因此，你创造了我们在其他教育领域看到的这种专业化水平，但它还没有发生，我认为，这在某些方面归因于多样性教育的历史和起源。
Well, you've been talking about how hard it is, if not impossible, to change people's implicit biases and that maybe the best thing that we can do is open people's eyes to the fact that they have these biases. but are there any promising lines of research on interventions that could really reduce people's implicit biases over the long term? There are, but they are often a much larger ask than what many people would want to do, which doesn't mean it's not the right thing to do, it's just very demanding. So we know that the types of experiences that most reliably reduce implicit biases, the ones that we can intentionally engineer within our own lives, is sustained contact with people that are different from us.
好吧，你一直在谈论改变人们的内隐偏见是多么困难（如果不是不可能的话），也许我们能做的最好的事情就是让人们睁开眼睛，看到他们拥有这些偏见。但是，有没有任何有前途的研究方向能够真正从长远角度减少人们的内隐偏见呢？有，但它们通常比许多人愿意做的事情要求更高，这并不意味着这不是正确的事情，只是要求非常高。我们知道，最可靠地减少内隐偏见的经历类型（我们可以在自己的生活中刻意设计的那种经历），是与和我们不同的人进行持续的接触。
So one of the classic studies finds that if you're a white college freshman and you're randomly assigned to a black roommate rather than a white roommate, your implicit racial biases will go down over the course of your first semester in college. So that shows at least while you're having some of these sustained everyday contact experiences, your implicit racial biases are changing in response. But oftentimes when we do find evidence like this, it really is day-in-day-out experience, which a lot of us, for a lot of us, is either difficult to do, motivationally or very difficult to do because we live in a racially segregated society. And so it's not easy to get contact, especially the type of high-quality contact with people of different backgrounds that we need. Where do our implicit biases come from?
因此，一项经典研究发现，如果你是一个白人大学新生，并且被随机分配到一个黑人室友而不是白人室友，你在大学第一学期期间的种族内隐偏见就会下降。这表明，至少当你有一些持续的日常接触经历时，你的种族内隐偏见正在发生改变以作出回应。但通常当我们发现这样的证据时，它确实是日复一日的经历，而这对于我们许多人来说，要么由于动机原因很难做到，要么因为我们生活在一个按种族隔离的社会中而非常难以做到。因此，获得接触并不容易，尤其是我们需要的那种与不同背景的人的高质量接触。我们的内隐偏见从何而来？
What we know is they have two common sources. One is they are in large part reflections of our knowledge and internalization of societal hierarchies at large, of who has more power, who has more status, who is more positively regarded within a society. And so this is part of why they may often diverge from our explicit biases, right? When we are seeing all of these stereotypes reinforcing certain racial hierarchies, such that, you know, white folks are the ones that are powerful and high status and admired and black folks are dangerous and criminal and violent, there's an imprint on aspects of our mind that are less conscious or less controlled and more spontaneous, that doesn't necessarily show up as much explicitly.
我们所知道的是，它们有两个共同的来源。一是它们在很大程度上反映了我们对整个社会等级制度的知识和内化，即在社会中谁拥有更多权力、谁拥有更高地位、谁受到更积极的看待。因此，这也是为什么它们有时会与我们的显性偏见产生分歧的部分原因，对吧？当我们看到所有这些刻板印象都在强化某些种族等级制度时，比如白人是强大、高地位和受崇拜的，而黑人是危险、犯罪和暴力的，这会在我们较少意识、较少控制、更自发的思维层面留下印记，而这并不一定在显性层面上表现得那么多。
So that's one part of it. But we also know that personal experience and our personal affiliations matter a lot. So the largest systematic difference in Pacific racial bias we see between groups is that between white folks and black folks. And a large part of why that is is because, you know, if you are a white person in America, right, you're more likely to have white family, white friends, white significant others, your own sense of yourself as a white individual. and all of those things feed into a sense of favoritism for one's own group and a motivation to like things that are affiliated with one's own group.
所以这是其中的一部分。但我们也知道，个人经历和个人归属感非常重要。我们在不同群体之间看到的内隐种族偏见的最大系统性差异，是白人群体与黑人群体之间的差异。造成这种情况的很大一部分原因是，如果你是美国的白人，对吧，你更有可能有白人家人、白人朋友、白人重要另一半，你作为一个白人个体的自我意识，以及所有这些都会助长对自身群体的好感，以及喜欢与自身群体相关的事务的动机。
You see that black folks also have, you know, a set of experiences that encourage favoritism for one's own group as well. And so when you put those two things together, that explains a lot of the variation in implicit racial biases across societies. So are we living in a time now where what had been implicit biases are coming to the fore and they're becoming explicit because there's so much dog whistling going on out there that it's giving people permission to act out what they would normally not? So I see, and this is me more speculating. Maybe it's not a fair question, but I ask it anyway. It's a great question. So I'm going to just put a little bit of grains of salt here because this is just my opinion on the matter. But I think that there have been a couple changes over the past four or five years that I think have really changed the nature of how racial bias is expressed in the United States.
你会发现，黑人群体也有一套鼓励对自己群体有好感的经历。因此，当你把这两件事放在一起时，就解释了社会间内隐种族偏见的很多变异。那么，我们现在是否生活在这样一个时代：过去曾是内隐偏见的现象正在浮出水面，并变得显性化，因为外面有太多的暗号（dog whistling），这给了人们许可去表现出他们平时不会表现出来的行为？所以，我看到——这更多是我在推测。也许这不是一个公平的问题，但我还是问了。这是一个很好的问题。因此，我将对此持保留态度，因为这只是我对此事的个人看法。但我认为，过去四五年里发生了一些变化，我认为这些变化确实改变了美国种族偏见表达的性质。
The first is an increase in the normalization of expressing racism. So Chris Crandall at the University of Kansas has these great studies. with depressing results, finding that in the aftermath of Trump's election to presidency in 2016, levels of prejudice did not appreciably change. If anything, people reported less racial prejudice. And perhaps that's because they were comparing themselves to the commander-in-chief. That's what was sailing in mind. But where you were seeing a large change was changes in perceptions of whether expressing
首先是表达种族主义的正常化程度有所提高。因此，堪萨斯大学的克里斯·克兰德尔（Chris Crandall）做了一些很棒的研究，结果令人沮丧：他发现，在特朗普2016年当选总统之后，偏见水平并没有明显改变。如果有的话，人们报告的种族偏见反而减少了。也许那是因为他们把自己与总司令进行了比较。那是脑海中盛行的看法。但你看到巨大变化的地方，是对表达
prejudice is normal or okay. And what we know from research in social psychology and other fields is that oftentimes our perceptions of what's normal is a larger driver behavior than our actual personal attitudes are, right? So our personal attitudes might have changed the same, but we might feel more free to express our racial bias. On the flip side, though, we also know, particularly with the resurgence of Black matter over the past couple months, that there's also been a sea change explicitly in
偏见是正常还是可以接受的看法的改变。从社会心理学和其他领域的研究所知，通常情况下，我们对什么是正常的看法，比我们实际的个人态度更能驱动行为，对吧？我们的个人态度可能没有变，但我们可能会感到更自由地表达我们的种族偏见。不过另一方面，我们也知道，特别是随着过去几个月“黑人的命也是命”（Black Lives Matter）运动的卷土重来，美国人对种族关系的看法也发生了根本性的转变，以至于对种族不平等现象的存在以及我们必须采取行动这一事实（或者至少是必须采取行动的观点）的想法有了更大的支持或认可。
how Americans think about race relations, such that there's much greater support or endorsement for ideas about the existence of racial inequality and the fact that we must do something about it, or at least the opinion that we must do something about it. And so part of what might have change in the culture too is a sense of a gradual change in what counts as blatant racism, right, compared to, say, 20 years ago or so, right? Things that might have seemed okay 20 or 30 years ago, you know, maybe some instances of blackface to us seem now way beyond the pale. And so I don't want to discount the fact that there's also just been a lot of cultural change in terms of our thresholds of what counts. as racism as well, such that some of these classic scales that indirectly measure racism, these questionnaires, are perceived to be blatant measures of racism from some survey participants
因此，文化中可能发生改变的一部分，也是关于什么算作露骨种族主义的标准在逐渐发生变化，对吧？与大约20年前左右相比，对吧？20年或30年前可能觉得没问题的事情（你知道，也许某些涂黑脸扮黑人（blackface）的例子），对我们来说现在似乎远远超出了底线。因此，我不想低估这样一个事实：在我们的种族主义衡量标准（即标准）方面，也发生了很多文化变革，以至于其中一些间接衡量种族主义的经典量表（这些问卷）现在被一些调查参与者视为露骨的种族主义衡量标准。
nowadays. It kind of speaks to the whole Me Too movement that's happening as well. When you talk about things that were acceptable, say, 20 years ago, that now people are waking up and saying, I can't believe that women endured that kind of treatment. Oh, yeah. So it all seems to be of a piece now. Yeah, exactly. And I think that these changes are happening so slowly, so gradually, we don't notice it.
这某种程度上也说明了正在发生的“我也是”（Me Too）运动。当你谈到大约20年前被接受的事情时，现在人们醒悟过来并说，我简直不敢相信女性忍受了那种对待。哦，是的。所以这一切现在似乎都是一体的。是的，完全如此。我认为这些变化发生得如此缓慢，如此渐进，以至于我们没有注意到。
But then if you think about your mindset five years ago, you're like, wow, a lot has changed. And we can see this in some of our, you know, national studies of prejudice as well, where there is a lot of change going on, but it doesn't feel like it on a day-to-day basis. One of the things where we have seen a C change in reductions of both implicit bias and explicit bias is, in attitudes toward lesbian and gay individuals. We see a huge reduction in explicit prejudice, and we've also seen a large reduction in implicit prejudice toward gay and lesbian people over the past 15 years. And so we can have our little tiny interventions
但如果你回想一下你五年前的心态，你会觉得，哇，发生了很多变化。我们也可以从我们的一些国家偏见研究中看到这一点，这些研究中正在发生很多变化，但日常感觉并不明显。我们看到内隐偏见和显性偏见都发生根本性减少的领域之一，是对女同性恋和男同性恋者的态度。在过去15年里，我们看到显性偏见大幅减少，对男女同性恋者的内隐偏见也大幅减少。因此，我们可以进行我们微小的干预措施，
that are looking at what happens if you give people this five-minute media experience, and maybe it doesn't move the needle that much. But what the HRC and all these other organizations and all these media exposures are, they're not doing one time. They're doing hundreds, thousands of times over, years. And probably that very difficult to capture a process of thousands of media exposures
这些干预措施着眼于如果你给人们这种五分钟的媒体体验会发生什么，也许它并不能推动多少改变。但是人权运动组织（HRC）以及所有这些其他组织和所有这些媒体曝光，它们不是做一次。它们是在多年里做了几百次、几千次。可能那个极难捕捉的、历时多年的数千次媒体曝光过程，
or thousands of, you know, everyday life exposures over years is what's accumulating, aggregating into that large scale reduction and prejudice. But again, we can't capture that in the lab with a dumb experiment. Right. Right. And maybe something like Black Lives Matter can have that same impact, but it has to persist for years and years. Yeah. And to me, that's one of the things that's really tricky in this research where we're trying to design these field experiments to look at prejudice reduction where, you know, we can capture this small representative slice of it, but it's quite different from living it day in and day out and being in a culture where the the sands are shifting in a particular direction. And you're getting, you know, an ad here,
或者数千次日常生活的曝光，正在积累、聚合为那种大规模的偏见减少。但同样，我们无法在实验室里用一个愚蠢的实验来捕捉这一点。对，对。也许像“黑人的命也是命”这样的运动可以产生同样的影响，但它必须持续数年之久。是的，对我来说，这是这项研究中非常棘手的事情之一，我们试图设计这些现场实验来观察偏见的减少，你知道，我们可以捕捉到其中的一小部分代表性切片，但这与日复一日地生活在其中、身处一个沙子正朝着特定方向移动的文化中是完全不同的。你得到了，你知道，这里有一个广告，
a TV show there, a movie there, a friend mentioning, you know, a gay or lesbian friends, you know, there, like all those things presumably are adding up. But that's, that's very hard to study in terms of how do we capture this adding up process. Right, right. So where is the research going? What are you looking at next? And what do you think we need to be studying more? I mean, I think that, you know, the studies on diversity education are coming out now. And it feels like there's been kind of a lag where, you know, clearly there's been a lot of public interest in it, but not that much of a database or evidence base to know, well, how do you do it well? When is it going to work or not?
那里有一个电视节目，那里有一部电影，一个朋友提到（你知道，一个同胞或女同性恋朋友，你知道，在那里），所有这些事情大概都在累积。但这非常难研究，我们如何捕捉这个累积过程。对，对。那么研究将走向何方？你接下来在关注什么？你认为我们需要更多地研究什么？我的意思是，我认为，你知道，关于多样性教育的研究现在正在问世。感觉好像存在某种滞后，你知道，显然公众对此有很多兴趣，但没有那么多的数据库或证据基础来了解，好吧，你如何才能把它做好？什么时候它会起作用，什么时候不会？
And so what I'm excited for is to see some of this research, see the light of day in the next couple of years so that we know, is diversity training something that we ought to do for our personal organization? And if so, how do we do it? Because I think right now there's a lot of shooting in the dark, some of which might be working, but some of which might not be. Well, how does a workplace know if their diversity training is working? So I think what I would recommend to an organization right now is to do an analysis of what are the metrics that we care about most here? Is it something like we just want to make people more aware of the existence of bias?
因此，我感到兴奋的是，在未来几年里看到其中一些研究见天日，这样我们就知道，多样性培训是我们自己的组织应该做的事情吗？如果是这样，我们如何做到这一点？因为我认为现在有很多盲目摸索的情况，其中一些可能有效，但其中一些可能无效。好吧，工作场所如何知道他们的多样性培训是否有效？因此，我认为我现在会向组织推荐的做法是，分析我们这里最关心的指标是什么。是我们只想让人们更多地意识到偏见的存在吗？
And that's a reasonable educational outcome if you're just doing a short session. Or do we want to shoot a little bit higher, right? Do we want to change perceptions of what the social climate is like among the employees? It's to actually change hiring and promotion practices. So I think what I would suggest to organizations, identify the metrics that you care about and then work backwards to think about what are the solutions that are most effective for achieving that metric. And sometimes that might be diversity training that is focused on that topic. And sometimes it might not be.
如果你只是做一个简短的课程，这是一个合理的教育结果。还是我们想把目标定得更高一点，对吧？我们是想改变员工对社会氛围的看法吗？是为了真正改变招聘和晋升实践。因此，我认为我会向组织建议的是：确定你关心的指标，然后逆向思考，找出实现该指标最有效的解决方案。有时这可能是专注于该主题的多样性培训。有时可能不是。
Well, you've left us with a lot to think about. I think there are still a lot of open questions on this topic, but I appreciate you're joining us today. It's been really interesting talking to you. Great. Pleasure to speak. Great. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.
好吧，你给我们留下了很多值得思考的东西。我认为关于这个话题仍然有很多未解的问题，但我感谢你今天加入我们。与你交谈非常有趣。太好了。很高兴交谈。太好了。谢谢你。你可以在我们的网站上找到“心理学热线”以前的节目，网址是www.
www. speakingof psychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA. p.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
www.speakingofpsychology.org，或者在你获取播客的任何地方。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以给我们发电子邮件，邮箱是speakingofpsychology at APA.org。那是Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，在APA.org。Speaking of Psychology由李·温曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康丁（Chris Kondyin）。感谢收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。